back in the 1979 or so I was trying to
build my first big computer system and
trying to figure out you know how should
I represent computations at a high level
and I kind of invented this idea of
using kind of symbolic Expressions you
know structured as it's kind of like a a
function and a bunch of arguments but
that function doesn't necessarily
evaluate to anything it's just a a thing
that sits there representing a structure
and so building up that structure and
it's turned out that structure has been
extremely it's it's a good match for the
way that we humans it seems to be a good
match for the way that we humans kind of
conceptualize higher level things and
it's been the last I don't know 45 years
or something it's served me remarkably
well so building up that structure using
this kind of symbolic representation but
working say about abstractions here
because you could just start with your
physics project you could start at a
hypograph at a very very low level and
build up everything from there but you
don't you type shortcuts right uh you
take the highest level of abstraction
convert that
uh the kind of abstraction that's
convertible to something computable
using symbolic representation
and then that's your new foundation for
that little piece of knowledge and
somehow all of that is integrated right
so the the sort of a very important
phenomenon that that is kind of a thing
that I've sort of realized is just it's
one of these things that sort of in the
in the future of kind of everything is
going to become more and more important
is this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility and the the question is
if you know the rules for something you
have a program you're going to run it
you might say I know the rules great I
know everything about what's going to
happen
well in principle you do because you can
just run those rules out and just see
what they do you might run them a
million steps you see what happens Etc
the question is can you like immediately
jump ahead and say I know it's going to
happen after a million steps and the
answer is 13 or something yes and the
the one of the very critical things to
realize is if you could reduce that
computation there isn't a sense no point
in doing the computation the place where
you really get value out of doing
computation is when you had to do the
computation to find out the answer but
this phenomenon that you have to do the
computation to find out the answer this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility seems to be tremendously
important for thinking about lots of
kinds of things so one of the things
that happens is okay you've got a model
of the universe at the low level in
terms of atoms of space and hypographs
and rewriting typographs and so on and
it's happening you know 10 to the 100
times every second let's say well you
say great then we've we've nailed it
we've we know how the universe works
well the problem is the universe can
figure out what it's going to do it does
those 10 to the 100 you know steps but
for us to work out what it's going to do
we have no way to reduce that
computation the only way to do the
computation to see the result of the
computation is to do it and if we're
operating within the universe we're kind
of there's no there's no opportunity to
do that because the universe is doing it
as fast as the universe can do it and
that's you know that's what's happening
so what we're trying to do and a lot of
the story of science a lot of other
kinds of things is finding pockets of
reducibility that is you could have a
situation where everything in the world
is full of computational irreducibility
we never know what's going to happen
next the only way we can figure out
what's going to happen next is just let
the system run and see what happens so
in a sense the story of of most kinds of
science inventions a lot of kinds of
things is the story of finding these
places where we can locally jump ahead
and one of the features of computational
reducibility is that there are always
pockets of reducibility there are always
places there always an infinite number
of places where you can jump ahead
there's no way where you can jump
completely ahead but there are little
little patches little places where you
can jump ahead a bit and I think you
know we can talk about physics project
and so on but I think the thing we
realize is we kind of exist in a slice
of all the possible computational
irreducibility in the universe we exist
in a slice where there's a reasonable
amount of predictability and in a sense
as we try and construct these kind of
higher levels of of abstraction symbolic
representations and so on what we're
doing is we're finding these lumps of
reducibility that we can kind of attach
ourselves to and about which we can kind
of have fairly simple narrative things
to say because in principle you know I
say what's going to happen in the next
few seconds you know oh there are these
molecules moving around in the air in
this room and oh gosh it's an incredibly
complicated story
um and that's a whole computational
irresistible thing most of which I don't
care about and most of it is well you
know the air is still going to be here
and nothing much is going to be
different about it and that's a kind of
reducible fact about what is ultimately
a an underlying level of computational
irreducible process
and uh life would not be possible if we
didn't have a large number of such
reducible Pockets uh yes Pockets
amenable to uh reduction into something
symbolic yes I think so I mean life in
in the way that we experience it that I
mean you know one might you know
depending on what we mean by life so to
speak the the the experience that we
have of sort of consistent things
happening in the world the idea of space
for example where there's you know we
can just say you're here you move there
it's kind of the same thing it's still
you in that different place even though
you're made of different atoms of space
and so on this is this idea that it's uh
that there's sort of this level of
predictability of what's going on that's
us finding a slice of reducibility in
what is underneath this computationally
reducible kind of system and I think
that's that's sort of the thing which is
actually my favorite discovery of the
last few years is the realization that
it is sort of the interaction between
this sort of underlying computational
irreducibility and our nature as kind of
observers who sort of have to key into
computational reducibility that fact
leads to the main laws of physics that
we discovered in throughout his century
so this is we talked about this in in
more detail but this is a uh to me it's
kind of our nature as observers the fact
that we are computationally bounded
observers we don't get to follow all
those little pieces of computational
irreducibility to stuff what is about
out there in the world into our minds
requires that we are looking at things
that are reducible we are compressing
kind of we're extracting just some
Essence some kind of symbolic essence of
what's the detail of what's going on in
the world that together with one other
condition that at first seems sort of
trivial but isn't which is that we
believe we are persistent in time
that is yes you know uh so some such a
causality here's the thing at every
moment according to our Theory we're
made of different atoms of space
at every moment sort of the microscopic
detail of what what the universe is made
of is being Rewritten and that's and in
fact the very fact that there's
coherence between different parts of
space is a consequence of the fact that
there are all these little processes
going on that kind of knit together the
structure of space it's kind of like if
you wanted to have a fluid with a bunch
of molecules in it if those molecules
weren't interacting you wouldn't have
this fluid that would pour and do all
these kinds of things it would just be
sort of a free-floating collection of
molecules so similarities with space
that the fact that space is kind of
knitted together as a consequence of all
this activity in space and the fact that
kind of what we consist of sort of this
this series of of uh you know we're
continually being Rewritten and the
question is why is it the case that we
think of ourselves as being the same us
through time that's kind of a key
assumption I think it's a key aspect of
what we see as sort of our Consciousness
so to speak is that we have this kind of
consistent thread of experience well
isn't that just another
limitation
of our mind that we want to reduce
reality into some that kind of temporal
yes consistency is just a nice narrative
right tell ourselves well the fact is I
think it's critical to the way we humans
typically operate is that we have a
single thread of experience you know if
you if you imagine sort of a mind where
you have you know maybe that's what's
happening in various kinds of Minds that
aren't working the same way other minds
work is that you're splitting into
multiple threads of experience it's also
it's also something where you know when
you look at I don't know Quantum
Mechanics for example in the insides of
quantum mechanics it's splitting into
many threads of experience but in order
for us humans to interact with it you
kind of have to have to knit all those
different threads together so that we
say oh yeah a definite thing happened
and now the next definite thing happens
and so on and I think you know sort of
inside uh it's
it's sort of interesting to try and
imagine what's it like to have kind of
these uh fundamentally multiple threads
of experience going on I mean right now
different human Minds have different
threads of experience we just have a
bunch of Minds that are interacting with
each other but we don't have a you know
within each mind there's a single thread
and that's a that is indeed a
simplification I think it's a it's a
thing you know the general computational
system does not have that simplification
and um it's one of the things you know I
I people often seem to think that you
know Consciousness is the highest level
of kind of things that can happen in the
universe so to speak but I think that's
not true I think it's actually a a
specialization in which among other
things you have this idea of a single
threat of experience which is not a
general feature of anything that could
kind of computationally happen in the
universe so it's the feature of a
computationally limited system that's
only able to
observe
reducible pockets